all right and we're we're back I hope
you had a wonderful Kwanzaa mit romney
has has come out and attacked President
Trump Mitt Romney has not even taken
office yet and as the new senator from
Utah
but he's already published an op-ed in
the Washington Post attacking Trump's
character his fitness for office he says
that the president has quote not risen
to the mantle of the office and then he
says some other stuff too now I think
that that that I could I can say this
with some credibility okay I think you
know that it's I'm telling the truth
when I say that I have no problem with
people criticizing Donald Trump it's
there are some conservatives who will
get very teary eyed and tummy hurt when
you say anything critical about Trump at
all for any reason in any context I am
NOT one of those people I criticize
Trump myself all the time in fact I
think that criticizing presidents is a
in general is a is a wonderful thing
it's an American pastime we should all
be criticizing the president all the
time matter who the president is that's
that's the relationship that we as the
people should have with the president it
is one of skepticism and criticism
that's that's the American Way
you should do it when you wake up in the
morning first thing like over breakfast
you should be criticizing the president
doesn't matter who he is that is a
healthy and good practice but which is
one of the reasons why I think it's
really unfortunate when you've got
whether it's a Democrat president
Republican president you've got a
Democrat president so that Democrats
feel like they have to defend in no
matter what Republicans feel like they
have to defend the Republican president
there's just a very unfortunate dynamic
because no matter who the president is
we should all enjoy criticizing him or
her because that is the American Way
it's what our founding fathers would
have wanted that said the question must
be asked can Mitt Romney specifically
criticized Trump specifically and be
taken seriously while doing it I think
the answer to that question is obviously
no let's just follow for a second let's
follow this very
path of this relationship between Trump
and and Romney over the last five or six
years Romney sought Trump's endorsement
in 2012 and he got it
then Romney attacked Trump in 2016 then
then Trump won and Romney went to trump
asking to be Secretary of State
then Romney sought Trump's endorsement
for his senatorial run in Utah and now
Romney's attacking Trump again so
there's a lot that's a lot of
vacillating a lot of back-and-forth you
know I want your endorsement oh you're a
terrible person oh can I work for you oh
can you have it could I have your
endorsement again oh you're a terrible
person again it just it has the air of
opportunism of hypocrisy of something
extremely extraordinarily self-serving
and fake on the part of Romney Romney
has a reputation as a flip-flopper and I
think that this only reaffirms that
reputation this is not and that's not
really what Romney wants to do instant
think he wants to reaffirm the
reputation as a flip-flopper because it
really hurt him in his presidential run
now the thing is I've always liked Mitt
Romney okay I think that he would have
made a good a good president I think
that if he does more than write op-eds
about the president he'll he'll make a
pretty good senator too but this is just
this is just nonsense and it's it's
shameless nonsense Romney going between
these extremes between condemning Trump
on such a fundamental level this and
this is not just when he condemns Trump
he's not just doing it on oh I disagree
with this policy or that policy he's
attacking his character his his
integrity which again is fine if you're
if you're gonna do that fine
but then you can't turn around and say
can I work for you or can I have your
endorsement what do you why would you
want the endorsement of someone who you
think is is dishonest an unfit president
has no character so on and so forth so
it's just it's just it's you can't
possibly take it seriously
and I also there's one other thing about
Romney that um I think needs to be
pointed out and again I say this as
someone I like him
generally as a politician I wish you won
in 2012 but there is something really
disturbing to me about a person who
cannot stop running for office like
someone who is addicted to running for
office obviously Hillary Clinton is a
top offender in this category but Romney
is - Romney ran for the Senate in the
90s and lost then he ran for governor
knee won then he ran for president and
lost and then he ran for president again
and lost and then he ran for Senate
again at the age of 70 and like I said
obviously he's not unique a lot of our
current politicians are like this they
just keep running they can't stop they
just keep on going and going and going
they must have political power they
cannot accept a world that they don't
partially control think about think
about Joe Biden Joe Biden is is probably
going to run for president at the age of
78 Joe Biden has been in political
office in in positions of political
power for you know five or six decades
or whatever and now he's gonna be 78 in
2020 and he's gonna run for office again
rather than just going home you're 78
years old life expectancy for men I
think is 84 or 85 so according to normal
life expectancy range you've got you
know you've got six seven years of life
left and so rather than just going home
to be with your family and to enjoy the
last few years you have left you're like
you're running for office you're
campaigning it's an addiction now I know
that if we want to be optimistic or if
we want to be generous which we should
never be generous to politicians but if
we want it to be optimistic or generous
about them maybe we would say well these
people have a passion for public service
right
they just they really want to they want
to help and they want to be well it we
could say that but but really if you're
if you're rich and you've been in power
forever and you're old now and you
really have a passion for helping then
go then you could volunteer at a soup
kitchen I mean if you're running for
Senate or president it's because you you
need to be in control you cannot accept
a reality that does not feature you in a
position of power and control so that
even apart from from his from this
back-and-forth with Trump Romney is just
another one of those guys even if he
seems like a pretty decent guy and all
that as I said but this you just keep on
running you can't let it go and it's
it's kind of disturbing it it really it
is an addiction and and I'm concerned
about I guess that's my point
all right so now I want to talk now
about a few stories that that's quite
enough politics for my first my first
day back so I want to talk about a few
stories that that nobody really cares
about anymore and and that's my point
really that's why I'm talking about them
I I was on vacation for a week last week
and then I had to work on New Year's Eve
and then I was off again for New Year's
Day and now I'm back today so on Monday
as I kind of wandered bleary-eyed back
into the wilds of the Internet and
social media I had been you know I
hadn't paid attention to any of that
stuff for you know seven or eight days
which was very nice but I'm back in it
as part of my job so I got to go on
Twitter and I got to go on Facebook and
social media and and figure out what are
the what are the controversies
everyone's talking about today what did
I miss
right and I discovered on on Monday I
discovered that people on Twitter were
very very mad about something which you
know they're always mad about something
and so on on Monday
they were very very the thing that they
were very very mad about was was louis
c.k who's a comedian he apparently made
jokes if you can believe it just just
get a load of this louis c.k a comedian
made jokes at a comedy club during a
comedy set I know that's very upsetting
and the jokes were vulgar and they were
edgy and they were inappropriate he
joked about he he had some material
about the parklands school shooting he
joked about that's the edgy
inappropriate then he also joked about
about gender fluidity or whatever which
is which is perfectly fine but the point
is those are the exact kinds of jokes
that louis c.k has been telling for two
decades where he's joking about things
that you're not supposed to joke about
really edgy you know inappropriate stuff
that's what he's been that's been his
shtick that's what he's been doing for
20 years and it's exactly the kind of
thing that once earned him basically
worshipful praise like deifying praise
from the very people who were now very
very mad about the jokes that he made so
people were upset about that and then
there was also at some point in the days
prior to that I got wind of another
outrage that I had missed there was
outrage over comments that have been
made by a TV chef named Andrew Zimmern
who's the host of a show called Bizarre
Foods which is actually one of my
favorite shows I love that show
anyway he made he made comments about
Chinese food restaurants in the Midwest
apparently Zimmern said that Chinese
restaurants in that part of the country
are horse crap only he didn't say crap
he used the S word now this is an
observation that every person who has
ever eaten Chinese food in the Midwest
has also made probably verbatim because
they are horse crap for the most part
same for Mexican food in the Midwest
same for a lot of different kinds of
food in the Midwest
Isak there are some good there's some
good food too in the Midwest but a lot
of
bad food you know if I'm if I'm just
being honest but people were very mad
about it especially on Twitter and they
said it was they thought it was racist
it was this in that and then it ended up
with production on Zimmern's Travel
Channel show being halted because of
comments that he made about Chinese food
restaurants in the American Midwest
there was another outrage that I missed
over the over the Christmas break Chris
Rock apparently got into some trouble
for not correcting Ricky Gervais s and
louis c.k yet again when they used the
n-word on an HBO show seven years ago
now this one takes a little bit of
explaining so back in 2011 Ricky Gervais
is Louie CK Chris Rock and Jerry
Seinfeld apparently filmed some sort of
discussion show for HBO where they sat
around in a room on chairs and they
talked about comedy for an hour and you
know so that was the show actually watch
part of it when I heard about this it
was actually kind of interesting but
during the course of the conversation
Gervaise and CK joked about the n-word
and about how they themselves sometimes
use the n-word during their stand-up
sets and then Chris Rock it was the only
black guy in the discussion instead of
correcting them he egged them on and he
joked around also about the word with
them now nobody cared about this for
almost an entire decade right for like
seven or eight years nobody cared nobody
noticed nobody just nobody cared then
suddenly some very mad people on Twitter
discovered the clip posted it and a two
or three day Twitter outrage cycle
ensued which I basically missed the only
reason I'm aware of it is that people
emailed me about it but if you go on
Twitter now you're not going to see any
hint of any of this and you especially
won't see any hint of any of these
internet Twitter social media outrages
if you put down your phone and you go
out and you interact with people in a
three-dimensional physical environment
here's
is a really fun experiment okay
don't actually do this because it'd be
kind of awkward but if you were to just
walk down the street and then stop a
random person who's walking by you and
say to them hey what do you think of
that whole Chris Rock controversy or say
say hey what's your take on those
offensive jokes at Lucy Kay told or you
could say like excuse me
what's your opinion on Andrew Zimmern's
comments about Midwestern Chinese food
now I would bet you $100 that the first
50 people you stopped will answer with
some version of what in the world are
you babbling about and that's because
normal humans in the real world don't
care about any of this they aren't
paying attention to it they have no idea
what people on the internet are very mad
about or why they're very mad about
those things and they aren't gonna take
the time to find out because they simply
don't care the people that you encounter
in in the world are concerned about
things that are much closer to them and
much more relevant to their lives so if
you're in line to the supermarket the
woman in front of you she's not thinking
about what Ricky Gervais said on HBO in
2011 she's thinking about she's getting
all our coupons together and that's what
she's thinking about or if you drive by
a guy in traffic he's not thinking about
he's not he's not dwelling or stewing
over I'm over offensive jokes that louis
c.k told her - comedy club last week
he's thinking about he's worried about
layoffs at his job or something like
that the girl sitting across from you at
the coffee shop she's not worried about
Chris Rock or or what Andrew simran said
about Chinese food she's studying for
her exam that she's gonna have in a
couple of weeks that's the those are the
things that people care about and and we
should also keep this in mind that even
if the girl at the coffee shop or the
guy driving down the street or the woman
in front of you at the supermarket even
if one Oh even if they actually did stop
at some point during the day to write an
angry tweet about the outrage of the day
they still don't really care because
obviously when we you know we can't when
we can't we can't really have this firm
delineation between the real world and
the Internet
because people in the real world are on
the internet so it may be if you stop
someone on the street they may in fact
be aware of these things and maybe they
actually said something about it maybe
they voice their opinion but they aren't
going to do anything with their outrage
that's the point
they aren't spending all day thinking
about it it costs a person nothing at
all to send an angry tweet or to post a
can you believe that so-and-so said such
and such type of Facebook post you can
churn that out kind of reflexively and
then you go back to your day and it
doesn't really matter to you and that's
the most striking thing about Internet
outrage is that it is so utterly
completely aggressively consistently
empty and meaningless it has almost no
natural real world correlation or
consequence and I say natural because
obviously it does have artificial it can
have artificial real-world consequences
so people on the internet we're very
upset about whatever Kevin I don't even
what was the Kevin Hart thing Kevin Hart
got in trouble I know he lost his
Academy Awards gay I don't even remember
anymore
what he got in trouble about the you I
don't think anyone does but that's
another one no one really cared about
that there was a lot of outrage online
but it's another one if you'd stop
someone on the street they would say
they either wouldn't be aware of it or
they really wouldn't care and they
wouldn't want to talk about it in spite
of that though and although it was empty
artificial meaningless outrage he really
did lose his Academy Awards job over it
Andrew Zimmern really is you know
suffering professional consequences as
well but that's only because the
decision makers in these companies these
corporate decision makers they don't
understand this extreme
the obvious point that I'm making right
now and then that you already knew so
they cave to this non-existent pressure
and they think that a bunch of mad
tweets actually means something when
they really don't they don't realize
that they could simply ignore this stuff
and it would all go away within a few
days if the Academy Awards had just
completely ignored the Kevin Hart thing
nobody would care right now just like
nobody cares nobody cares now about the
Kevin Hart thing and that would be the
case no matter how the Academy Awards
reacted to it they could have just
completely ignored it said nothing about
it pretended it wasn't happening and
within a few days everyone has moved on
to the next thing so it doesn't matter
but these people they kind of like
surrender and cede to the demands of
Twitter avatars for no reason they
remind me of an armed security guard
who's frantically opening the bank vault
for a six year old with a squirt gun
it's just there's no you could hardly
even call that robbery you can't even no
you can hardly blame you can't even
blame the six-year-old for you blame the
security guard now obviously it doesn't
help that while you've got these
cowardly corporate decision-makers on
one hand you also have the media which
will so often inflate the significance
of these very mad internet posts they
write whole stories and construct whole
narratives around the angry Tantrums of
six or seven random nobodies on social
media they they tell the right story
saying outrage has erupted because of
something that louis c.k said or
whatever and then when you look at it
you see that the eruption consists of
like a few dozen people who are writing
salty tweets about it that's that's not
interruption that's not what an eruption
is an eruption is a is a volcano it's
lava spewing all over the place and
destroying everything in its wake that's
not what internet outrage does the
internet outrage is not an eruption it's
more like flatulence it's just this
gross annoying sound that smells bad and
then disperses itself into the
atmosphere and five minutes later you
didn't eat you know you it's it's like
it never happened
so just hold your nose for a few seconds
and wait it out that's how you respond
to it so I think this is what we need to
do collectively we need to treat
internet outrage with the dismissive
contempt that it deserves we should just
laugh in its face
or better yet yawn in its face and then
put our phones down and live our lives
and that's it knowing that somewhere out
there in cyberspace people are whining
because so-and-so said such-and-such and
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter at
all it is just sound and fury and angry
faced emojis signifying nothing that's
the incredible thing is that when you
put your phone down and just walk away
from it it's like a tree falling in the
forest with no one there to hear it
that's all it is
I think I've told you before that I
myself have been have had I've been the
target of Internet outrage many times
and I've had the experience where I get
I've experienced it both ways I've had
the experience where the internet
outrage is coming fast and furious at me
and I'm in the midst of it and I and I
for some reason I'm not able to put my
phone down and so I'm reading all the
comments and I'm getting all the emails
and everything and sometimes in those
moments it can feel very real and you
could you feel like this really means
something and and maybe you even get a
little nervous you think like oh no
what's going to happen
but then I've also had the experience of
I don't know I'll send a tweet or
something and then I'll just put my
phone down and go about my day not
knowing that the tweet goes viral and
people are very angry about it and I'm
getting hundreds of messages and
comments and people are freaking out
and I'm oblivious to I didn't even know
that it's happening and then a day later
I'll go back online and I'll see that
this happened and it's already
evaporated the outrage has already
evaporated
and I just missed it so then I can say
oh okay
well so that happened people were upset
about that who cares that's the way it
always goes it's just it doesn't matter
one other thing for the rest of the week
for the rest of this week anyway people
will be talking about their new year's
resolutions and asking you if I'm sure
you've already been asked this question
but people are gonna be asking you what
what are your resolutions and so on and
so forth well I've got that question
already a few times I have an idea for a
new year's resolution that we all can
make okay and here's the new year's
resolution we should resolve to stop
making New Year's resolutions I think
that's the best New Year's resolution we
all could make because here's the thing
there's a reason why New Year's
resolutions are notoriously short-lived
and it's not just New Year's resolutions
by the way New Year's resolutions get a
bad rap but it's not just New Year's
resolutions that are short-lived its
resolutions in general in fact I would
say that that you can always be certain
or almost always be certain that a
person is not going to do a certain
thing if they ever announce a resolution
to do that thing and you can be sure
that they're going to continue doing a
certain thing if they've ever announced
a resolution to not do that thing
anymore
now I know this is true in my life um
there are good things that I've
successfully started doing good habits
that I've successfully formed and there
are bad habits that I've successfully
broken not many on either count
admittedly but it has happened but the
point is win on the rare occasion I have
actually successfully formed a good
habit or broken a bad one it has never
happened after announcing my intention
to do it now I have many times announced
my intention to do this in this or not
do this in that and on in every case I
have not followed through but on the
cases where I've actually done the good
thing continuously for
the good habit broken the bad habit I
didn't even notice that it was happening
while I was doing it in fact like as an
example I have many times resolved to
start eating healthier as we all have
and then most of the time when I make
that announcement and I say to someone
who Evers around me to my wife or
someone today yo for now on I'm gonna
start eating healthier and then three
hours later I'm drinking a milkshake but
there have been times when I've when
I've suddenly kind of stopped and
noticed and said wow I've been eating
healthy for six weeks and that's because
I never really officially resolved to do
it
I never said from now on etc I just I
just did it that's all like Nike I just
I just did it so my my cliched and
self-help ish kind of point that I want
to make is is that things are simply
done
you make the choice in the moment to do
it or not do it with bad things or
unhealthy things you make the choice in
the moment to not do it or do it and you
can't make a years-long choice you can't
make a choice that lasts even six weeks
you can't make a choice that even lasts
six minutes the choice lasts for the
moment that you make it and then it
dissipates and you have to make it all
over again continuously until it becomes
a habit and even when it's a habit
you're still making a choice it's not on
autopilot it's just a little bit easier
so if you were really gonna start
exercising or eating right or whatever
else you would just do it you would just
start doing it not on some arbitrary day
or time or at some special moment not
with any ceremony attached to it but
just now in the moment right now so if
you were eating a Big Mac last week and
and then you were thinking to yourself
come New Year's I'm not gonna be doing
this anymore then most likely here we
are on January 2nd you've already
probably broken that resolution you're
probably eating a Big Mac right now as
you're listening to this if you're
serious
about a certain choice you would just
make that choice and initiate it
whenever you happen to think about it so
you would make the choice on January 2nd
or March 12th or April 4th or or
whatever just on some random day at
whatever random time it pops into your
head
and you would just do it those are the
only resolutions that mean anything the
resolutions that are not really
resolutions at all but are just simply
good momentary choices followed by
another good moment or a momentary
choice and so on you know what the only
I'll tell you the only real function of
New Year's resolutions is just to make
you feel better
while you're making bad choices up until
New Year's so that's that's that's
really the only reason why anyone ever
announces that they're gonna start
eating healthy because nine times out of
ten when you make that announcement
you're announcing it as you are eating
unhealthily so it's just your way of
making yourself feel better
about the about the thing that you're
doing right now which is the opposite of
a resolution but if you were serious
about eating eating healthy you just
wouldn't have ordered the Big Mac in the
first place
the fact that you ordered it means that
you're not serious about it yet and so
that's it so that's my that's my
self-help sermon for the day whatever a
good thing just just do it in a moment
and then do it in the next moment and
then on and on all right we will leave
it there but I hope you all did have a
good New Year's and I'll talk to you
tomorrow
Godspeed